[Music]
we're going to divide into two teams and
compete against each other where we have
to make two meals with carrots and stir
and I just want to say real quick that I
think cooking is really important
especially cooking healthy food because
I'm guessing a lot of you programmers
and college students spend most of your
time in front of the computer and maybe
sometimes you skip a meal or you just
eat ramen well as you start to get older
you'll realize that health is really
important so yeah make sure that you
take care of your health with exercise
and by eating healthy and because of
that you'll probably be a lot more
focused and can probably be a lot more
productive teach you guys some money
coworkers
this is my boss Jay coworker it's the
boss he tells me what to do is that true
what is your role everybody tells me to
give Gemma where our questions do many
actual role that's all your piano and
basically what the s people do that's
the answer but yeah buddy that's true
he's my boss not quickly enough
they say that here Cyrus stories you
think I would change me did my hand it
doesn't even oh my god Ann's too small
bro oh you guys I look at Oh what are
your numbers your peak your peak yeah
haha how much did you weigh and how much
did you lift 45 are dead lifted five ten
squad 452 your 1.45 like bling is
posture this is the humble brag posh
secret I just look at Cyrus and I guess
okay send me some of your lifting clips
out I'll put them right here too
Wow the caption what a man or cyrus what
a man he pretends to be camera shy but
he's actually humble bright yeah we saw
are you Indian thousand-pound Club wait
what's the call yeah thousand Club yeah
of course of course
easy easy bro sure tell me about your
role my role manager
ooh matter wow you seem very young so
[Music]
are you 20 yes already that's yeah the
way that the oceans of Kevin but yeah so
for a sparring stock what can you tell
them tips succeed check out your most
videos on tips
we don't take stylus track in the car
interview out that book was what all my
jobs
what about once you get into the comedy
succeed I would say learn as much as I
can from the most senior engineers
play write more code I think like my
personal opinion is so you merge
yourself just get yourself situations so
just like sports I think you have to
practice practice and practice like in
sports you wouldn't just read about the
sport and then one day hope to be the
best at it you know you have to practice
you have to put in the hours and you
have to develop those muscle memories
same thing with coding you can't just
read about it and try to optimize for
like the best learning experience in the
end you just have to get your hands
dirty and start coding so I tried to
infiltrate the other team and gets Intel
about what they're making so are you
guys making Abishag like what's the
final meal unfortunately he was as
clueless as I am clearly people who work
in Silicon Valley do not cook for
themselves even lift bro oh [ __ ] that
sounds really good dude
wait William yeah let me give my viewers
some sense you guys smell it would you
say did you say thank who's that yeah
it's around me I don't touch that dude
yuck quick quick dab it I want to I need
to make mmm what what's the hardest
thing about being an engineering manager
hardest thing yeah wait the light is
better than this side Oh chef
[Applause]
rational or logical code so it's a
little trickier what's the most common
problem that you have to debug in people
usually I think the biggest thing for
for entertainment hmm
debugging you till I will really get
some excited projects for them for their
passion your engineers very well Sanjay
Sanjay
[Applause]
for realsies though how did you do it
chose me yeah let's do a real answer
look at the camera not me
[Music]
Peter science minor oh really I didn't
know that oh [ __ ] my quick comments look
about it so it's nice bicycle bell rings
can you stop please not doing p.m. not
being fit for are you doing I see data
analytics no way that's what I do
development marketing and partnerships
transitions like I always say if I do
you recommend people going to data
analyst if they can go to p.m. right
away but do you recommend people to go
the data analyst before going to piano I
would say that in order to come very
good man you have to learn I do
everything else that's sure that you're
really bad you can always be a good
start but if you wanna be a great P on
the other however all the other or it's
been together amazing p.m. thank you so
much thank you so much
whoa that looks heavy are you jacked
have you working out oh oh
so this is this is a result oh my god
you drop some stars yeah that's right
that's right what is it oh that looks
delicious
Abhishek yeah how can we be successful
as a software engineer like yourself
you're stealing what do you mean by
stealing impact yeah the cauliflower
steak yeah okay all right real answer
now if you want to succeed as an
engineer and get promoted what should
you do you finally said our master
in their team agree that is the most
impactful thing okay what do you mean by
impact I hear that word a lot what does
that mean it means you have a goal that
you're a famous try
you figured out of the funds that you're
working on
so you can't just do whatever your boss
asks you to do right does it all these
folks are pretty tough
your boss doesn't always ask you do
things that's good by the way Kevin what
do you do for work oh so does that mean
you're a product manager can't tell me
how you got into the road that doesn't
do anything because I really want to do
that role I was optimized
[Applause]
cooking is fabulous what do you what do
you what do you miss most about being a
soccer engineer non-manager I miss
coding you have miss coding so are you
saying engineering managers don't quote
a lot anymore when you have a smaller
team you do but larger teams do you ever
regret becoming a manager because you
like people
[Applause]
so Alton tell me about yourself I can
tell you basically Gordon Ramsay
how long have you been working as a
software engineer for oh wow so you must
be really really senior 7017 oh my god
can you tell me more about the ease when
do people start III right and you're at
seventeen fresh fresh 20 now being 40
years old how do you keep your
complexion so smooth as a 40 year old
simple showering is overrated
oh my Oh overrated thank you this is my
perfect complexion
thanks so much Elton yeah
[Music]
my Calexico I don't know I don't really
see any definition a little bit so then
we get that delicious chicken now the
thing is you know you don't care about
this jargon this type of attorney
because Indian social it tastes like
right but most importantly is how I made
it we made it as a team harmony that's
why we look at this what does it look
like
yes exactly she's making yang because
it's all about harmony and bonding for
teammate so we didn't just make this
food for hands we made it
you know speech on the laptop yeah all
right so power point and see we had a
very strong team effort this half across
functions management yes we greatly
exceeded expectations you can see we
have a nice spread of a mix of
vegetables we grilled some state we
combine that's a nice chilled salad and
we tossed up with a nice pineapple
dessert so you can see we hit our
milestones early
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
check it out is this oh hell yeah
[Music]
are you serious isn't your bathroom
bigger because it's two sinks oh I love
this lighting oh I like the mirror
lighting it makes you look Jack yeah all
right so probably one couch here another
couch here your huge couch here
projector on the screen all right so I
hope you like that quick tour I don't
want to show you everything yet and also
I want to decorate this place before
giving it tour okay but yeah so anyways
we're gonna we're going to go back to
work now
okay we're gonna go to the gym hit hit
the weights
yeah all right guys so after a long day
of work I usually like to you know just
exercise a little bit now why do i
exercise I think you guys should all
exercise too because it's really
important to keep fit because obviously
when you code all day you know it's not
very healthy because you're sitting
around all day and also another thing
that's important I don't want to
reinforce the negative stereotypes of
programmers so I think everyone should
go to the gym it's good for you because
you're cold better and also so that we
don't look like nerds oh yeah these few
squats
it's a warm-up set give it my shoes
so we're gonna start with 95 pounds five
five reps or warm-up yeah make sure you
got a sturdy grass you can pop that but
okay today we're going to try to hit a
PR meaning one map what is it one map
rep max one rep max Mott one rep max
meaning I just did one rep and I want to
see how much I can do yeah and he's
wishing me luck
this is 205 this to a fine yeah alright
my coast again 215 by the end of this
month but we're gonna try this first
215 by the end yeah because I think
that's what intermediate is how much you
weigh 132 pounds
alright so we're going for 225 I think
that would pass the intermediate level
for my weight loss
all right thank you for watching this
video I hope you enjoyed it you know so
now I can see what I do drink day in my
life and yeah I'm pretty happy I hit 225
it's still a long way to go though but
yeah I hope you guys will join my
journey getting jacked yourself am
[Music]